SHE-HULK
Alright, let's do this.
TATIANA MASLANY
What's so fun about She-Hulk
is that there are a
lot of unexpected cameos.
Hulk.
HOLDEN HOLLIWAY
Blonksy.
SHE-HULK
Wong.
BRIDESMAID
Titania.
SHE-HULK
I will kill for you, Megan Thee Stallion.
MEGAN THEE STALLION
Oh, you are way more fun
than my last lawyer!
GINGER GONZAGA
Megan's a really good actor.
TATIANA MASLANY
I'm a huge fan. Like it was crazy.
KAT COIRO
You think of this huge star,
but Megan was just awesome.
MEGAN THEE STALLION
I am doing groundbreaking things.
Twerking in Marvel.
And I like to think of myself
as a version of Thanos.
THANOS
I don't even know who you are.
[Laughing]
JENNIFER WALTERS
Just remember whose show this actually is.
KAT COIRO
Every episode introduces a
crazy cast of people. There's so much
more to come in this wacky world.
HULK
Boom!
MEGAN THEE STALLION
Eh.